(coughing)
- So smooth!
- Old Monk.
It is from India.
- I am drinking the
liquor of my ancestors.
- I didn't know you were Indian.
- Yeah!
- Great.
- What'd you think I was?
- I don't know.
- These three though.
- And it's pornographic, XXX.
- Namaste!
- Ha!
- A little bit stronger than I expected.
- It's good rum!
- It's got almost like a
maple syrupy thing to it.
- If I was like really alone and sad,
I'd throw this on my pancakes.
- It's like eating Indian
food, but in a liquor form.
It just keeps...
(Indian music)
- Indian rum, good, you
guys know what you're doing.
- Indian rum, thumbs up.
- Jinro.
- Jinro!
- It's Soju.
- From Korea!
- You're in the same
terminal as a Cinnebon.
- 24% feels like a lot.
- Like a strong one.
- If you take full shots of it,
it's like half the alcohol content.
So you can just throw them back.
- Jinro.
- Wait, that's the easiest
shot I've ever taken.
I almost could mistake it for water.
- I could drink that all day.
- Reminds me of just like
a much more reserved syrah.
- Love me some Jinro.
- What is this called?
Moutai Yingbin.
- Moutai--
- Mou--
- Moutai.
- Is this the one with
the snake inside of it?
- How much like percentage
of liquor's in it?
- A (beep) staggering amount.
- It's 106 proof.
- It comes out like a cleaning product.
- This is Chinese Everclear.
- Oh God, oh my God.
- It smells like someone farted on, like,
some fruit rollups.
- Here we go! Baijiu!
- Ooh!
- Oh, oh!
- Oh my God!
- Oh my God! Jesus Christ, no.
- It tastes like poison.
- It's like a divorce in my mouth.
- Under no circumstances
should this be consumed.
- I gotta be honest, I like baijiu.
- Are you, ugh, serious?
- I dug that. That was great.
- Yokaichi Mugi.
- Product of Japan.
- The packaging reminds me of, like...
- A prop from Howell's Moving Castle.
- It's sort of like chocolate.
- Yeah, like what is that chocolate.
- Almost chocolatey, almost, right?
- Mm-hm.
- What is it?
- It smells like a bathroom.
- That's not bad.
- That's so smooth.
- I don't know what
else to say, except mmm!
- It's not very alcoholic,
it's not like a liquor,
it's more like a wine.
- It's saki-esque.
- It's very similar to the Soju.
- It's the Soju vibe
with the Moutai flavor.
- Yeah, Japan wins.
- Always, always.
- Girl, you want some Yokaichi Mugi?
Whatssup.
- Mekong, enjoyed with friends.
- This is my favorite looking bottle.
- This looks like something
from like "Casablanca".
- The seedy Thailand underbelly
people are drinking this.
- Kickboxing and Mekong,
that's what Thailand does!
- This smells good, actually,
- It smells like Jameson's.
- Yeah!
- It smells like whisky.
- It smells like vodka.
- It's not bad!
- No.
- It's a little syrupy.
- Syrupy.
- If someone put Thai iced
tea in my Grey Goose...
- Mekong!
- Drink, drink, drink, drink!
- You know, Asia likes to get drunk
just like the rest of us, right.
We've got bad alcohol
that gets the job done.
They've got bad alcohol
At the end of the day, we're
all just trying to get silly.